resuelve p igual a 12 l 2 w
para l estaque tenemos aquí es la
fórmula para el perímetro de un
rectángulo el perímetro es igual a 2
veces el largo más 2 veces el ancho lo
que nos están pidiendo es que resolvamos
esa ecuación para él entonces tenemos
que es igual a 2 l más 2 w necesitamos
despejar l para eso dejaremos este
término que contiene el del lado derecho
y los demás términos los voy a pasar del
lado izquierdo para lograr esto
prestemos 2w vamos a restar 2 w del lado
derecho y para que no se altere la
igualdad necesitamos también restar 2 w
del lado izquierdo del lado izquierdo
resulta p - 2 w
2 w lo cual es igual del lado derecho
que nos resulta estos dos términos dos
dobles menos dos de blues se cancelan y
nos queda tan solo 2 l y ahora para
despejar l necesitamos dividido ambos
lados de la ecuación entre 2 dividimos
entre 12 el lado izquierdo y entre 2 el
lado derecho
nos queda dos sobre dos se cancelan y ya
hemos despejado la l que es igual a
menos 2 w sobre 2 o si queremos
escribirlo de la manera usual él es
igual ap - 2 w sobre 2 y así hemos
concluido